[Musique]
sécurité m entre chaque personne la
technologie nous aide mais elle n'est
pas elle n'est pas suffisante 1 la
présence humaine est déterminante à un
drone qui va remplacer un fonctionnaire
de police ça va de soi mais ça fait
partie
ça fait partie de
de l'information soit pour des
événements faire ses courses à la
pharmacie quand promener son chien faire
un petit peu d'activité physique mais
c'est tout et le reste du temps il faut
que je sois je peux pas le dire
autrement
restez chez vous
[Musique]
là j'en prends l'engagement du soignant
v12
merci merci à vous y allez
o en sont les attestations qui sont qui
sont produits téléchargeables qui
doivent être remplies de manière
manuscrite papier a présenté et dès lors
qu'il ya un défaut ou que le motif est
il légitime ou faire ses courses à 15 ou
20 kilomètres de chez soi
bien évidemment ce n'est pas légitime
[Musique]
norio plus à ton corps des mines rues et
nos policiers agissent avec discernement
je tiens à vous dire que les
instructions je l'aurais donné c'est que
plus les gens vont passer plus l'écart à
la règle sera sanctionnée immédiatement
[Musique]